what does it feel like to have garry
kasparov back playing chess
garry kasparov is definitely one of the
two greatest chess players of all time
it's either him or bobby fischer but
personally I choose him because he's
done so much for chess just world
without Gerry's like imagine Queen
without Freddie Mercury it's always
great when when he plays young the
tournament feels a little bit different
I don't know why he is always strong in
the openings now I think people will be
interested to see what type of player
Gary is without any openings in Fischer
random it's much more important to
intuitively sort of feel where the
pieces should be and how to play as
opposed to say actual preparation I
think from that standpoint Gary is
probably one of the strongest players
ever when it comes to intuition and his
feel for the game of chess so it's gonna
be quite interesting he was the biggest
hero I had growing up he was a person I
built my repertoire on I built my
approach on him as much as I could when
I was a kid oh the only negative thing
about playing an event featuring Chris
Barb's I don't get to play with him you
know and I had to choose my opponent I
guess bar was my first choice but you
know if you don't ask the pretty one to
the prom right away you end up with
Maxie
of course I'm delighted to be playing
with MBL he's a fantastically strong
opponent I'm a little worried that I'll
be distracted by watching kiss borrow
pledges because he was my hero growing
up where I really enjoyed just how
dominant he was with this sort of non
compromising very sharp chess I believe
that my appearance with the chess board
can help to promote the game it's
amazing to actually be part of of this
chess experiment in 21st century where
we have all the modern technology you
have hundreds of thousands of people
follow you through internet and all
these other means of communication and
at the same time you know just you have
this unique cloud of of traditional
chess events